on this the fourth day of the fourth
month of the year of Our Lord 2022 The
Washington Post is finally admitting
that Hunter Biden peddled his father's
influence for big bucks all around the
world now many people have suspected the
Biden family's cash for favors scheme
for many years now but we've had
irrefutable evidence of it since October
14 2020 when the New York Post reported
on the contents of Hunter Biden's laptop
hard drive which revealed lots of
degenerate sex stuff and more damningly
lots of financial chicanery implicating
not just Hunter but his big guy father
too
when that story broke two years ago the
entire liberal establishment conspired
to shut it down I had actually forgotten
until just now we posted a brief special
on it outlining what was in the laptop
what it really meant and we were called
conspiracy theorists and Kooks and
cranks and crazy people turns out we
were 100 correct you know how much I
hate to say I told you so but you can
find it on my YouTube channel you were
not allowed to post this sort of this
article at least to social media you
were accused of fake news if you even
talked about this thing you could not
privately message it and the papers of
record all denied it the Washington
post's fact Checker reported fact
Checker quote unquote that he had quote
not been able to verify or authenticate
these emails
said that there were fears that the
emails could be part of a broader
disinformation campaign by Russia a slew
of other Washington Post op-eds called
the hard drive contents unverified said
they had never been authenticated and
called the whole report sketchy
the rest of the establishment media did
exactly the same thing the New York
Times and all the rest of them now
however the Washington Post is running
big headlines
inside Hunter Biden's multi-million
dollar deals with a Chinese Energy
company Hunter it turns out made 4.8
million dollars in retainer and
Consulting fees from a dodgy Chinese
Energy company in just 14 months because
of his expertise in Chinese energy I
don't think so I think more more to do
with his last name Tony babulinski who's
a businessman who worked with the bidens
on their business in China has gone on
the record admitting that 10 Equity was
being quote held by H Hunter for his
father the big guy Joe Biden has been
caught with his hand in the cookie jar
we are talking about an historic degree
of corruption
and the most left-wing establishment
papers of all of them are admitting it
the question we should be asking
ourselves is why why are these Shameless
propagandists all of a sudden turning on
the Democrat president
is it because suddenly they've given up
their Decades of dishonesty they've
become honest newsmen overnight
or is it because Biden's ratings are in
the gutter his presidency is a failure
and the establishment finally wants him
out before conservatives celebrate the
left's confession that they lied about
the laptop and rigged the presidential
election two years ago perhaps we ought
to focus on the present and ask what are
the swamp creatures up to now
I'm glad you like that clip now
subscribe ring the bell get
notifications head on over to Apple
podcasts or Spotify or Stitcher or
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the Michael Noel show leave
a five star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]